it all seems so wonderful FTX the
world's second largest crypto exchange
was was changing everything it was
revolutionizing not just crypto and
finance but the whole world through
effective altruism through the funding
of the most wonderful idealistic largely
Democrat politicians all over the United
States it was all just so beautiful
until it all came tumbling down and it
turned out that FDX was actually just a
bunch of kids living in a Bahamas
Penthouse doing a ton of drugs and
sleeping with one another and spending
gazillions of dollars that didn't
actually really exist now I know
absolutely nothing about crypto or
Finance or the Bahamas for that matter
but fortunately we have one of the OG
leaders Inc crypto Eric Voorhees who has
debated the man in question here that
would be Sam bankman freed s b f and who
has really approached crypto not just
from a money-making perspective but from
a philosophical perspective as well and
uh Ken I think shed some light on what
the hell happened Eric thank you so much
for coming on the show
hey Michael thanks for having me
I truly know
nothing about crypto I have been reading
the reports of what happened here at FTX
I still I don't quite get it the best I
can deduce is that the whole thing was
kind of a Ponzi scheme
what happened
yeah let's start it with the basics so
um so yeah FTX was this massive exchange
uh fairly new on the scene like it
didn't even really exist three or four
years ago
um but suddenly it was the second
largest exchange it had its name on the
Miami Heat stadium
um it was doing Super Bowl ads with
um Tom Brady and Gisele
and um everyone thought it was like one
of the most successful companies in the
entire industry
um it had a related company called
Alameda started by the same guy prior to
FTX Alameda was a prop trading firm they
would trade their own money make
speculative bets on various things
within the crypto world and without
and um FTX was a exchange for customers
so people that want to buy and sell
cryptocurrencies would go to FTX to do
that
what seems to have happened is that
Alameda made a bunch of losing bets very
large losing bets billions of dollars
perhaps earlier this year
and it borrowed the missing amount from
FTX
FTX lent customer money over to Alameda
so FTX had billions of dollars of
customer deposits who were trying to
trade their own cryptocurrencies it lent
that money unbeknownst to those
customers to this other company
and um that seems to be what has
happened generally the details are still
all coming out but there's something
around 10 billion dollars missing
which is an absurd an absurd amount and
the behavior of SBF
since the the collapse last week has
been also very strange and extraordinary
so I'll stop there and we can dig into
whatever you want fools and their money
are quickly separated but you're talking
about some pretty serious people with
some pretty serious money and then a ton
of other kind of regular run-of-the-mill
retail investors who are using this
Exchange
how did nobody figure out that the whole
thing was kind of a scam
well Twitter figured it out uh crypto
Twitter figured it out just people using
blockchain forensics figured it out and
that's kind of what started this all
unwinding
um it certainly wasn't the government
that figured it out it certainly wasn't
Regulators that figured it out it
certainly wasn't the police anywhere
they figured it out it was just private
people doing some investigation and um
so it it was discovered because
um
basically they had to stop uh having
customer withdrawals they had to pause
them and that's always like a huge red
flag there should be no point where a
custodian is ever pausing withdrawals
that's that's a problem so imposing it
because they didn't have enough money to
to fund it right I mean this is the sort
of thing we read about in the 1930s or
you know right after the stock market
crash that that uh
this this Twitter thread emerges and
they say actually
FTX is completely screwed and then
people come in and they say Okay I want
to get my money out of here and it's
basically like a run on the bank and and
the bank or the exchange the FTX in this
case doesn't have the funds and so they
say okay we're going to put a pause on
it and then no one has any faith
whatsoever in the institution anymore
and then the whole thing just collapses
instantly
yeah the comparison to a bank is the
right one so just like with banks FTX
operated on what's called a custodial
model where it's holding customer money
so a lot of things in crypto are called
self-custody where you're holding your
own Keys you're holding your own crypto
and you don't have to worry about
whether people are trustworthy but still
people deposit funds with third parties
and in this case the third party was FTX
and just like a bank that doesn't
actually have all the money in it that
people think it does uh FTX did not
either but unlike a bank FTX does not
have a backstop of taxpayers in the form
of FDIC insurance so when the Run
started it all all fell apart you have
to feel sorry for the people who lost
their money even Tom Brady or whoever
but there is something really
satisfying here which is that SP SBF the
guy who was running this thing
was so flamboyantly
liberal I don't know he he was so
effusive about effective altruism and
how he was going to transform the world
and he wasn't really in it for the money
you know he was just in it for all the
good that he could do for everybody else
and then it turns out it was just
complete BS the guy is a common criminal
basically
yeah well he he was the second largest
donor to the Democratic party in this
last cycle something like 40 million
dollars I'm awaiting those politicians
to return all that money so that it can
go into the relief fund for the victims
that would be nice well uh I I hope
you're not holding your breath on that
Eric because I I don't think that would
be conducive to your health
so the the
basic scheme here was the guy takes the
money out of
The Exchange and sends it over to this
hedge fund the hedge fund is being run
it turns out by this 20-something
Stanford Graduate girl who may or may
not have been sbf's girlfriend and who
publicly now it is
coming out I mean I guess it was public
before but no one was paying attention
to it was not uh implementing
even basic protections against some of
her her crazy bets that obviously
weren't paying off very well as
Investments and then they would all brag
about how they were hopped up on
amphetamines I I I guess what I still
struggle with is how did they get away
with it for this long
they got away with it for this long
because they had the Mirage
of protection under government
regulation happening ftx's marketing
campaign was the safe regulated way to
buy Bitcoin and digital assets
and it wasn't just a campaign Again Sam
was in Washington DC lobbying and
talking with all these Regulators he was
buddies with many of them there are all
sorts of photos of him with you know
Maxine Waters and he had meetings with
the chairman of the SEC Gary Gensler who
seems to have taken a very light touch
approach with him
um
people trusted it because it it flew
under the under the banner of Regulation
and unfortunately people trust the
government they should stop doing that
thankfully in crypto you can trust code
you can trust math you don't need to
trust politicians but people still do
and so that's part of what allowed this
to get so large and to collapse so
horribly you know I'm not a huge Ein
Rand guy but I have to admit this whole
episode just seems like something out of
Atlas Shrugged you know the really
crooked businessman who whose entire
wealth rests on favors that he's calling
in in Washington D.C I mean this guy Sam
bagman freed was just doing all of that
and it's not just The Regulators in DC
it was the media too I just pulled at
sort of at random one of the glowing
profiles of this man here's what they
said about his Bahamian business
operation
Sam bankmanfried lives there with nine
roommates fellow Travelers in effective
altruisms movement an intimate crew we
learned it was actually a very intimate
crew but that's beside the point it's
just SBF his family his mother father
and brother are all in town and close
friends a team dedicated to fixing the
world via the magic of quantitative
easing and the overwhelming force of
Goodwill all of them are united by the
mission goes on and on and on yes the
government Regulators failed here didn't
the media fail as well how come it's
just random guys on Twitter who were
able to expose this fraud where were the
journalists where are the financial
journalists who should have been poking
poking around the business operation
yeah well they like often abdicate their
responsibility in in the crypto World um
we get lots of Articles from the press
that are very damaging and and
um very cynical about what we're doing
but when it comes to someone like SPF
they write these glowing reviews why why
that discrepancy like the the good
leaders that have been in the space for
up to a decade at this point
um just get totally trashed by the New
York Times by The Wall Street Journal
myself included and then the biggest
fraudster that has ever appeared in
crypto comes along and they write these
glowing reviews about him even what came
out in the New York Times a day or two
ago post the collapse
um if you read it it's shocking like how
unwilling they are to acknowledge that
Sam committed like a absurd degree of
Fraud and theft here they don't even use
those words they talk about how there is
a collapse and like you know this thing
went off the rails and it just got this
Vibe of you know poor poor kid got ahead
of himself instead of
this guy stole customer deposits and
gave them to a sister company
and that is simply just fraud and Theft
it's not complicated it's not like some
Complicated new scheme was created using
crypto technology they just had a bunch
of customer money and they gave it to
someone else and it's just theft
you know I I did watch a debate between
you and this guy Sam bankman freed and
knowing absolutely nothing about crypto
I had the sense that you had the right
side of the debate because you gave your
answers in really plain concise language
and he would just Spin A Yarn forever
using all this kind of jargon and and
all of these kind of mealy-mouthed words
and I thought you know seems like the
guy is trying to hide something here and
and clearly that's the case but but as
you point out with the New York Times
the The Narrative that is emerging from
the collapse of FTX is that this was a
failure of too little regulation that
that the failure here was that uh you
know crypto itself is is sort of
poisoned or you know we just need the
government to come in there more and and
add some some more safeguards you say
it's exactly the opposite
yeah the problem here is that someone
committed theft and stole a bunch of
money
um theft doesn't require regulation it's
already illegal crypto doesn't need more
rules it already has a bunch centralized
custodians like this are already heavily
regulated under the bank secrecy act and
many other uh many other laws in the
United States and elsewhere
um those of us in crypto have seen how
much regulation we have and it doesn't
help people and here comes the biggest
fraudster ever and none of the
Regulators stopped it none of the
Regulators caught it
the industry caught it the industry
stopped it and for those of us who have
been building this stuff what we're
trying to advocate here is that people
realize that decentralized Finance
basically using Financial tools built on
blockchains where you don't have to
trust anyone is the future you can have
honesty through transparency and through
code you don't need to trust
um you know Tom Brady's endorsement you
don't need to trust Maxine Waters in her
you know 50th committee on financial
oversight you can just trust open source
code and that is incredibly powerful and
that's actually the right lesson to
learn from all this by the way I
remember what Tom Brady did to those
footballs okay I remembered deflategate
so I would I would never trust a crypto
exchange that he was endorsing but uh
maybe that's from my uh prejudices as a
New Yorker you know never never was a
big Patriots fan
moving forward you've got this defy
movement we're saying okay the
regulation is a big big problem here and
obviously there was a failure of people
being too cozy with these Regulators can
crypto
broadly survive this I mean because you
can say well then the narrative that's
being spun up by the media is total BS
but narratives have power
what does the collapse of FTX mean for
the broader crypto space
yeah so from a superficial level it's a
huge black eye for crypto right like in
irrefutably
um the fundamental question what's
valuable to understand is did anything
actually change with the technology that
would lead someone who had a thesis
about this to change their thesis
um nothing about crypto technology
changed there's no horrible bug revealed
in the consensus mechanism of Bitcoin
for example
um crypto blockchains keep working just
as they always have and they operate
according to code the failure here is a
failure of centralized financial
intermediaries and that's been happening
for hundreds of years there's nothing
nothing new to that but certainly people
who don't look under the surface or who
read the New York Times are going to end
up you know misled and that's that's a
shame I think you repeated yourself
there by the way Eric people who don't
look under the surface and people who
read the New York Times so I hope I hope
they can look elsewhere to uh to figure
out
the the reality of what is going on but
if you've got all this money that
basically disappears and who knows if
SPF you know flies off into the sunset
you know and leaves on a on a yacht from
the uh Bahamas you know with with some
crypto wallets in his pocket but
how are the other exchanges reacting to
this and and what do you think even if
it's ill-advised the regulatory action
from Washington is going to be
yeah so the other exchanges are
you know all reacting first in
telling people you know they they don't
act the same way you can trust them and
some of them are correct you can trust
them but that's also still missing the
point again the best way to use crypto
is in a way that you don't have to trust
humans that's the magic of the
technology that has come out so
decentralized exchanges haven't been
saying anything of course because
there's no people there
um it's just these Financial robots that
work according to code and that's like a
much better way to actually have a
foundation for economic interaction
between people
um one good thing that that should
happen from this is more of the
centralized exchanges may be encouraged
to do what's called proof of reserves so
you can actually do like a mathematical
proof of what you hold
um it's slightly technical but it can be
done in a way for the user where it's
where it's clear and obvious and that
would provide some degree of
verifiability
um so I'm hoping that that will happen I
think The Regulators are going to use
this as an opportunity to regulate more
they're not going to use it as an
opportunity to self-reflect and
recognize that they completely and
utterly failed at their job I can
guarantee you that they're just going to
use this to write more laws and impose
them down on a bunch of innocent people
so we've talked about what the effect
for crypto will be will there be any
effect will there be any black eye for
the effective altruism movement uh will
there be any black eye for the Democrat
Party will there be any black eye for
The Regulators or or no do you think
that just gets brushed under the rug
because this is kind of a technical
topic to discuss and most people are
just going to glaze over
well it's actually not a technical topic
it's just someone who had a bunch of
customer money stealing it and you don't
love someone else right but I mean the
industry broadly requires a little bit
of kind of technical know-how
yeah that's fair
um I don't really think this is actually
a story about effective altruism I mean
that's that's the idea that if you're
going to try to be generous you should
try to be effective in your generosity
and there's nothing wrong with that in
principle the reason that gets pulled
into this story is because it looks so
bad when you know one of the world's
foremost billionaire effective altruism
Advocates comes out as like the greatest
Ponzi scheme operator of all time
um this isn't actually even a Ponzi
scheme it's just theft so like we don't
need to come uh do you think there's a
comparison you know people are asking is
this Bernie Madoff is this Enron is this
I don't know any other number of huge
financial scandals is there is there any
analogy that you would draw
I think it's closer to Enron than Bernie
Bernie was running a a Ponzi scheme over
many years over the long term that
failed as Ponzi schemes must fail this
wasn't really a Ponzi scheme this was
just taking a bunch of customer money
and giving it to someone else I'm sure
that Sam thought that he'd get that debt
paid back and it would never be a
problem
right
but it was a problem so yeah there's
I don't know a good historical example
like this certainly within crypto a lot
of centralized exchanges have gone Bust
or had hacks you know that kind of thing
so it's not new within centralized
custodians
you've talked about your enemies in
Washington do you have any allies I mean
are there are there politicians that you
would point to who you think these guys
get it they get what crypto is and what
crypto could be and and they're moving
in the right direction on it
yeah there are a few and there's more
and more you know 10 years ago no one in
Washington cared about Bitcoin or crypto
five years ago no one in Washington was
an ally
um now there are there are some allies
um I don't actually want to name any
names because I'm kind of a persona non
grata in Washington and I don't want to
get them in trouble with their peers but
it has been good to see uh actual allies
that understand it and who speak
eloquently when they're discussing
cryptocurrency can I at least ask you
are you talking about regulator or
bureaucrat types are you talking about
U.S senators say or are you talking
about all of the above Senators senators
and congressmen I don't know that I've
seen any Regulators who are
doing a good job I will make one
exception which is Hester Pierce at the
SEC
she's been the most thoughtful perhaps
the only thoughtful regulator at the SEC
she has stood against many of the
decisions that they've made that have
been really bad so um yeah props to her
for both understanding what she's
talking about and for coming to the
right conclusions on it well that's
terrific I'm glad to hear that you've
got a little bit of support in
Washington even if you wisely don't want
to go about flaunting it you saw what
happened to the last guy who was
flaunting all of his political contacts
in Washington did not turn out very well
for him or for his exchange but thank
you for shedding a little light on
something that I I really uh you know I
just mired in all of the gobbledygook
jargon I couldn't make any sense of it
but you've distilled it pretty well A
guy stole a bunch of money and spent it
in ways that he shouldn't have uh tale
as old as time but in this case on a
very large scale uh Eric where where can
people find you if they want to read
more follow your thoughts and all the
rest of it
Twitter's great at Eric Voorhees Eric
with a k
um and you can find me there that's
great that's wonderful I uh look forward
to that uh speaking of freedom and and
you know getting rid of regulations
Twitter another another great place
right now where a billionaire is coming
in and hopefully making things a little
bit more free so I look forward to
seeing you over there and for all the
rest of you out there I look forward to
seeing you tomorrow I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show